foreign
[Applause]
Union before moving here when he was 11.
now an author and satirist he co-hosts
the trigonometry YouTube show Mostly
examining social and cultural issues his
recent speech in an Oxford Union debate
arguing for the end of so-called woke
culture has been viewed over 15 million
times if not more now constantly New
Town welcome
good evening panel rushy soon act States
integrity and accountability are
important to me canadim sahawi stay in
post after the tax disclosure Saga
Constantine we haven't heard from you
well Jake gave a graph and I admire
someone defending their friend but when
he described nadeem's Harvey as an
extraordinary vaccine Minister he was
extraordinary in his deceitfulness he
said that vaccine passports were
discriminatory and that they wouldn't be
introduced in this country before
proceeding to introduce them so it's not
someone that inspires a lot of trust in
me and hang on hang on a minute when you
say we had vaccine passports yes you may
mean something different by vaccine
possible we had the NHS app yes and we
could share he said that that would be
discriminatory and wouldn't be
introduced we didn't and then there were
lots of Israel there weren't we weren't
as for example they had been in China
forbidden from getting to literally well
I'm very grateful we didn't become China
so we didn't have vaccine passports in
that sense we had the program that he
said would not be introduced and
promised it wouldn't be introduced and
called it discriminatory but anyway
let's not focus on that if we come back
to to the point about this current
situation as you said yourself uh hmrc
the boss of hmrc said today that
innocent people don't pay panel no you
said there are no penalties I'm just
gonna be completely
there are no pen alty innocent errors in
your tax Affairs right that's what he
said so we can conclude from that he was
not an innocent error then and he wasn't
specifically talking about nazim he was
just talking generally but nadims of how
we paid a penalty yes so it was not an
innocent error can we agree on that
my opinion doesn't count folks I just
want to hear what you've got to say
just following the logic of what you're
saying but uh I actually do agree with
Jack I think there needs to be a proper
investigation but you should have
resigned on day one for that
investigation to happen and there is a a
touch of the Hancock about this an
unfortunate turn of phrase given why he
left
um because we're in a position where a
minister is dragging on a situation that
is clearly going to end up in them
resigning one way or another he's not
going to stay he's this is not
sustainable this is embarrassing the
Prime Minister it's embarrassing the
party and the sooner he resigns for a
fair investigation to take place the
better for uh for the conservative party
and for the country it
[Applause]
I make a very quick point on this which
is we've spent I think probably about 10
minutes talking about this 20 20. which
is what I'm thinking let's go on to the
next one well quite but the point I was
going to make is the reason that he
needed to resign on day one is precisely
because we are spending all this time
talking about when we've got a cost of
living crisis we've got a war in Europe
okay well in that case let's move on
Northern leaders so leveling up should
be hardwired into UK law to help close
the gap in living standards does the
panel believe this will help to tackle
unequal living standards
I say a lot about leadership
I think we talk about leveling up what
we should be talking about is leveling
with people here and the rest of the
country the reason that uh the disparity
that you talk about exists is that you
in this community and communities around
the north poor the brunt of
globalization and the industrialization
of this of this country and there's no
point building infrastructure if there's
no jobs for people I don't think what
you want here is government handouts I
think what you want is industry and
employment so that people can have a
decent job and dignity and
we actually have I mean I think the
world and this country in particular are
about to face a very very challenging
time economically but as
de-globalization happens which is
already occurring due to the breakdown
of Supply chains and so on what you're
going to see is actually we have an
opportunity to bring industry back to
this country and make things again in
this country and buy things made in this
country but that will mean that we have
to let go some of our obsessions like
Net Zero and so on and we will find out
if the government's prepared to do that
okay I know in the glasses
um
and just to pick up on what Constantine
said you are so wrong we do not deliver
a growing northern economy by turning
our back on Net Zero the north of
England this County this region is a
global leader in Green Technology we
deliver a better leveled up north of
England by having Green Collar highly
paid secure jobs for people who live in
this region Net Zero is the solution not
the problem I think it's good for your
voters to hear that um I'm sure
conservative party voters will be
pleased but um
but the other thing is I we currently
Outsource uh 50 of all our CO2 emissions
to other countries why don't we bring
that manufacturing back to this country
and make things here and have jobs for
people where we would make things
cleaner and there would be better
quality why don't we do that why do we
Outsource
this country Outsource our jobs these
people's jobs to places like China to
tyrannical regimes like the ones in
China the other countries around the
world instead of making things in this
country
and see the biggest wind farm in the
world just off the coast here built with
British steel that is about securing
jobs in scunthorpe other areas of the
country and delivering those highly paid
secure jobs because actually that's what
people you have another question
is part of the green industrial why do
we Outsource half of our production to
other countries why are things that
people buy in this country made in other
places we are not Outsourcing jobs I've
just we've just created a thousand green
jobs in West Yorkshire for young people
we know this is the future for our
regions this is how you level up is you
tackle the climate emergency and that's
why investing in Green Technology
investing in those jobs investing in
onshore and offshore and making sure to
your point about who who gets the
benefit to making sure that our wind
farms in Swansea don't then pay for
schools in Stockholm that's why the
labor party are focused on making sure
that we have sustainable Green Tech in
our country that creates amazing jobs
for Regions like like scunthorpe okay
I'm going to take another question
because a lot of people asked about this
is it a good idea for NATO to visit
Hawaii in UK forces with tanks oh it's
about World War III I don't think it's
going to spark World War III I think it
really depends on what people want if
you want to support Ukraine and to be
able to defend itself then we have to
provide them the things that they need
to be able to do that I personally
support that there are people who
disagree but it's not going to spark
world war three and actually I think how
can you be
I'm I'm not warmongering or
fear-mongering but how can you be so
short because a person is a we don't
know what he's thinking well it's very
clear based on what they've said is
they've called this a provocation but
they're not doing anything about it and
I don't think they're gonna attack the
West in response uh the West actually
has been pretty smart about this in that
they uh been gradually testing the
waters as opposed to just throwing lots
of stuff at them too and so it means
that there's a sort of marginal effort
every time it doesn't really allow
Russia to respond uh as aggressively as
they might otherwise have done as I say
it depends what you want if you want
Ukraine to survive then you have to
support them with the things that they
need otherwise you let Putin take over I
mean that's the choice
um and so I personally my view is uh we
should provide the ukrainians with what
they need to defend their country
because the next step which the lensky
is asking now for is fighter jets which
so far has been a red line for NATO
do you think that NATO should Supply
fine I think that the first thing nature
should Supply uh is the defensive uh
anti-aircraft and anti-missile systems
that will allow Ukraine to defend its
power stations and power supply networks
which is what Russia is currently
attacking I think that really should be
much more the conversation out of her
role so like you I'm half well I'm half
Russian half Ukrainian and I would very
much Echo the last point that you made
Jake people in Ukraine are immensely
grateful for the support that Britain
has provided I think we should be very
proud in this country and on behalf of
them thank you uh I I think they'd all
want me to pass that on can I quibble
with something you said Fiona briefly
about Germany because actually and this
comes back to the debate we were having
earlier the reason Germany's so hesitant
to support Ukraine is not some kind of
sentiment about World War II and a bad
look and all that the reason they're
hesitant is they depend on Russian gas
there's also great sensitivity in
Germany
but but the main driver of that
hesitation is the fact that they're
relying on Russian gas and this is why I
come back to the point about energy
security we have to produce our own
energy if we want to be safe in the
world it is essential that we do this so
it's very important and finally red
lines if you send troops British troops
into Ukraine you are going to be in
World War Three and I say that as
someone who's fiercely pro-ukrainian
who's opposed to Putin's Invasion from
the beginning that is a red line we must
not cross
[Applause]